the second key insight that i've taken
from this year's conversations is that
the best recruitment companies and
recruitment leaders are the ones that
genuinely put their people first
it's easy to say that you put your
people first but it's a whole different
story when it comes to executing that
what i mean by this is you have
recruitment companies now that have
great csr schemes contributing x
percentage of their placement fees to
the charities that they care about you
have companies really committing to
well-being in the workforce and
investing in people's mental health you
have companies really committed to
basically creating the best possible
culture for their teams to thrive and
again this may sound obvious but the
best companies the best brands in the
recruitment industry right now that i
see are the ones that generally put the
people of their business at the center
of everything they do and that's been
the really key insight that i've seen
this year that hopefully continues to go
into next year as well
[Music]
you